.
Thank you.
Oh, okay.
you not want to we sometimes be yes and now The audio in I can't take.
I'm going to mess.
I'll try this after.
Thank you.
Thank you very much for that.
All right, so to take advantage, first off, thank you very much for coming today.
We're having this, call this meeting, it's been a while since we have met, and the reason was to have functional assets advisory, as I call it, to take the best amount of time for our professionals for EPA, DES, health, et cetera, that when they come here, we have something substantive to meet about, and there has not been.
We are now coming close to the bedrock study being presented.
That will be part of our discussion on one of our points right here shortly.
And we wanted to get an update as to what has taken place within the last 12 months.
And it was very kind to have Mr.
Wimsatt as a read to put on a schedule.
He's here today to give an update to us from the DES.
And also we're going to have miss whitney hammond regarding the update and the status on the the new hampshire cancer registry and how it pertains to what we've been dealing with with the cancer cluster commission so with with that being said we'd like to start the meeting right now and like to call miss if mr wimpsat would take a position here so he could have a microphone in front of him along with the camera mr.
chair yes senator sherman wanted are we going to do a roll call uh of the members or do we not have a quorum well we don't have a we don't have a quorum sir okay and also there is some, and I'm glad you brought that up, Senator.
I was also talking to our dear colleague over here as well.
Although this was all noticed 45 days ago to make sure folks would be here, just attending is not taking place.
And also there are some who are no longer participating, and there hasn't been a replacement for them.
So at this point, and I was going through it, there's been a replacement in the leadership office relative to who is on committees, commissions, and so on, and they don't have an updated list as well.
So that's something that I am working on and hope to make that a reality if you need any help with the towns most of them are in my district yes so if there are appointees like mr.
dr.
Zuckerman I don't know if he's planning on ending but I also just want to be sure that it's in the record that there there are people who are on the commission who can't be here for health reasons, and because the House has not accommodated them, they are unable to participate.
And I think that's an incredible loss for the commission, that those members can't participate.
Well, that's where I was able to work for a, quote, for a better word alternative option which is what we have right now right and um and if there was a question that they i said just text me and uh and for me to make that happen that was one of our members in the past with uh well i'll just keep that it's some members and that's why we we have, we're on right now.
So I can see it.
If I could do one follow-up.
I would encourage the commission and the chair to consider having what we have in many other commissions and committees, which is where members present have to constitute a quorum, but members who cannot be present state why they cannot be present and then are able to participate in the meeting.
So if we can get an interactive as a goal, that would be great.
But I appreciate what you've been able to accomplish here today.
Okay, that will be – well, we have the – well, I'll just jump to it real quick here.
We have the next meeting proposed for the 24th of January and that's the guidance from the from Ms.
Dunville of the EPA our EPA liaison of contact when the bedrock report will be formally presented right so that's and that's on the I put on the agenda with the hope that those who were here would say, yes, that's confirmed so we can then confirm that meeting with Ms.
Dunbar.
That came from their recommendation that they would be ready to do it.
We were hoping for December.
It just didn't happen.
And the other obligations that all our professionals are working on.
So kind of jumped jumped ahead on the agenda on that one, but that's on the agenda copies that we have.
Yes, Chair, can I?
Yes.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
So when it comes to January 20th, I know we're going to have a real problem finding rooms because all the rooms are doubled up and we have a lot of bills.
I think we're being encouraged to try to use off-site, meaning agency spaces.
Have you considered that?
I don't know if we've gotten that far in terms of the – maybe it's going to be hard to find a room for the 24th.
What day of the week is – well, we're going to be meeting – That's a Monday.
But the House is going to be meeting Monday through Friday now because there's only not a day, depending on your committee.
The rooms, it isn't going to be as easy as it used to be to find rooms.
Well, I'll look at, well, we all should be looking at having that total participation for those who can't do it by word and by video.
So see what that alternative is, if it's not available here.
Right now, as of yesterday, I checked.
These rooms are available for scheduling.
Mr.
Jarrett, just because none of the chairs have tried to, the standing committees haven't been told until all their bills are in, they're going to allocate rooms based on the number of bills each committee and they haven't gotten all the bills over to them as yet so that's what's still delay and that is I'm just bringing it up as a point no I'm trying to say is that an alternative is maybe asking one of the uh the performance that is active such as environmental or hhs to um provide us an alternative site off not in the lb but in their buildings got it i know i'm planning on doing that with a couple of mine already so thank you okay thank Thank you very much.
Okay, we'll move.
Oh, Senator?
Senator Gray.
Just the point of interest I went back through the notes that I have in my folder looks like your quorum is 11 based on House Bill 495 of 2020 or excuse me of 2019 I think it is later than that.
I want the starting point.
And this is the challenge that we've had of those who to show.
So we still have something because have responsibility to our to our state is on this subject and that's when after waiting here uh since our last meeting that uh we're moving forward today and then we'll see see how we what the recommendations might be from from the members is that all right with you senator gray Again, I'm just trying to give you the line in the sand that you've got to meet if you do find out a report or whatever yeah reports due june in june of 2022 so uh that's uh your points well taken senator so to follow the the directions that we have folks to participate and to participate.
And now that being said, I'd like to then recognize Mr.
Wimsatt.
And thank you for putting this on your schedule.
Did you hit your – there it is, your red button.
And the floor is yours, sir.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
And good morning.
My name is Mike Wimsatt.
I serve as director of the Waste Management Division, and I am the commissioner's designate to this commission for the New Hampshire Department of Environmental Services.
So happy to be here before you this morning and wanted to really just, and recognizing as the chair has mentioned that it's been some time since our last meeting, thought it would be helpful to provide an update on activities that have occurred since our last meeting.
And I've really kind of broken up into four different categories that are on your agenda.
The first is activities related to the dead rock investigation.
The second is sampling activities in various MEDA soil, groundwater, and surface water.
And the third is EPA's recent completion of the fifth five-year review.
And the fourth are activities related to House Bill 494 and efforts to treat surface water in Barry's Brook.
So we'll start with the first one regarding the bedrock investigation.
And as the Chair mentioned, you know, that report on that investigation is due at the end of this year, so a more detailed discussion and presentation of those results will be provided at our January meeting.
But I just wanted to give you some summary of some of the things that occurred leading up to that since we last met.
So basically, one of the things, you know, the key facts of the bedrock investigation, which has been going on for a number of years now, is to test.
And that's a test where basically you select an appropriate bedrock well on the pretty and you do a prolonged pumping of that well and you monitor the impacts of that pumping on nearby wells, on drinking water wells, and that sort of thing.
And you can learn an awful lot about how the aquifer behaves under pumping conditions and make a lot of conclusions about how groundwater moves in the bedrock aquifer as a result of a pump test.
So that's why that is important.
And some of the work that was done, the Cochlear Landfill Group, which is a group of respondents who are responsible for doing the work related to this site, did select monitoring well 6, which was an existing bedrock well on the site, and to evaluate its adequacy for use as the pumping well for the pump test and that work was done they submitted a test a pump test work plan in october of 2020 and the agency approved that work plan with conditions on december 15th 2020.
and then that pump test schedule which was originally going to be in the fall of 2020 and for options was moved up to the spring of 2021.
And then that work did occur.
And basically, just in the interest of giving you some updates from what has occurred since we met, there was a new bedrock borehole, MW now called MW25, that was sited and drilled on DOT property that's to the west of the landfill.
That was done during January of 21 to support as a key monitoring point during the pump test.
So, that well was based on a review of historic data and a surface geophysical survey that was performed by the CLG group and reported to the agencies during the fall of 2020.
So that was installed and became part of the pump testing monitoring that went on during the pump test.
So a draft of the final bedrock investigation report, as I mentioned, is due at the end of this year, less than a month away.
And our plan is to, once received, DES will work with EPA to evaluate the data from the investigation and determine if there is existing or potential for future migration of site contaminants that may pose an unacceptable risk or environmental impact.
And should unacceptable conditions be identified, the two agencies will consider options to manage those concerns, including possible modifications to the remedy for the site.
So as I said, that report is due, and we will expect to have a more detailed discussion at our January meeting'm happy to take questions as we go just a quick question Mike where is well six I I apologize I I don't know sure exactly where that is on the site.
You have no idea?
You know, I do not know the answer.
Wells are identified on that plan, and we'll be able to pick it out, but I don't know specifically where that was.
Okay, we can get back next time.
yeah in our january meeting we'll have a detailed presentation on what was the ROC investigation, including the pump test, so you'll be able to get answers to those kinds of questions.
Sure.
And Mr.
Wimsatt, just a follow-up question on that.
Is that the report, can that be provided to us prior to the before so that all members have it and then people pick be prepared It's again.
It should be submitted at the end of this month And you know, it's absolutely public document we can provide If you would just like send it to me And I show that it gets to every member.
If you sign it, you'll see it's on that document there.
Thank you.
That's a new member of the commission, Representative Baxter.
Appreciate him putting it on his time schedule today.
Please continue, Mr.
Wimpsett.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
So the second item that I wanted to have occurred since we last met, and so by way of introduction and context, I think members of this commission are aware that there were concerns expressed, you know, going back to the 2016 timeframe about potential impacts on private drinking water wells in the vicinity of the site.
There's a variety of wells.
There are already some wells that were integrated into a sampling program, but additional wells were added.
A lot of sampling has occurred since that time of private wells in the area.
So I want to figure out how the best way to provide this.
It wasn't clear that they could plausibly be impacted by the site.
There was a lot of work done to evaluate the work with a few wells that were taken out of that sampling, but sampling certainly continues for a number of private drinking water wells in the vicinity of the site.
Also I want to note that during this interim period, CLG conducted its regular semiannual sampling of site wells and private wells, both in the spring and fall of 2021.
During the spring 2020 private well sampling, a PFAS compound called perfluorooctane sulfonamide was detected in a high concentration in those 2019 results from the two labs.
It didn't resolve this.
It wasn't clear whether that result was really real or not.
And so there was a lot of work that went into trying to run that to ground.
So consequently consequently, at EPA's request, CLG basically was requested to plan and implement procedures to conduct a replicate sampling program with two labs.
And a replicate set of representative samples were sent to both of those laboratories to try to figure out, kind of run this issue to ground.
And as a result of that, the study concluded that the occurrence of PFOSA from the laboratory where it had been detected was most likely due to a groundwater matrix interference.
It was not confirmed by the other lab.
And so, based on the work that was done, it doesn't know that PFOSA was actually present in that original water sample.
As a result, the agencies have approved CLG to utilize the laboratory that doesn't have any matrix interference problems with groundwater samples for future.
and most of it is the compound that we don't really have any federal, there are no federal or state standards for it.
We don't have a lot of information about its health effects.
But it appears that based on the work that was done, it was not actually present in that sample.
Can you just define matrix interference for us, please?
Thank you.
I'm glad to say that.
But the interesting thing here is to describe the specific other chemistry of a sample.
So you can imagine that the sample, I'll give you an example.
Thank you.
I'll give you an example here.
So if you send an example of these, you can try to get a compound in a very clean water.
And it has very deep beginning.
So if you take a sample of wastewater from a wastewater plant, there are a lot of chemicals in this.
And that's 10% of wastewater.
And it's more common for a major production of the current All right.
Is your mic on?
Hit the button.
Thank you.
And this one.
If you want to repeat that answer.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm not sure when it turned off.
So basically, simply stated, matrix interferences are when other chemicals or compounds in the sample interfere with the detection and quantification of a contaminant in that sample.
And keep in mind that we are looking at compounds in very low concentrations here in parts per trillion, which we don't, you know, just a few years ago we weren't typically operating in those ranges.
So, laboratories have made a lot of advances in their ability to detect these perfluoro chemicals in drinking water in the last several years to a point where now the typical samples that we look at for drinking water, private wells or from a water system, we're able to detect down to as low as one perpetration or even in some cases sub one perpetration concentrations of contaminants.
But as a result, there's a lot going on at the lab that people don't realize.
It's not a simple thing.
And so there are times when a particular sample and its chemistry may make it difficult for a lab to identify a compound at a low concentration or in some cases, as we think occurred here, the compound is misidentified.
It's basically reported as being present when in actuality it doesn't appear to be present.
And that's what's happened here.
So a lot of work was done to try to, you know, take duplicate samples and basically repeat the analysis using two labs to try to run this issue to ground.
And that's not uncommon when you have a detection you're not accustomed to.
Usually the remedy for that is to try to make sure it's real because you want to know if it's real.
It's to try to take replicate samples and then send them to two separate labs and see if the data is consistent.
In this case, it was not.
The work that was done led the experts to believe that that original detection was really not a detection.
So two questions.
The first one, just to clarify, what you're saying is the repeat sampling did not show detection of the PFOSA.
That's correct.
Okay.
The second one is, has PFOSA been identified within the confines of the length within the?
I don't have specific data, but my understanding is it has been identified in some monitoring wells on the site in the past.
Okay.
Thanks.
And Mr.
Wimpsack has suggested we have a copy of what you're utilizing.
Yeah.
I brought an extra copy of this and I can provide it to the clerk so that it can be, and to the members as well.
Yes.
I can also send an electronic copy after this meeting.
Thank you, sir.
So the next thing I will mention, and it's not really identified as an item on the agenda, but I'll just mention it because it is something that occurred during the interim period here since our last meeting.
We have been providing agencies, both EPA and DES, providing site updates via email.
those updates are included June 16th, November 2nd, and September 29th, or June 16th of 2020, November of 2020, and September 29th of 2021.
And that was the following issuance of EPA's fifth five-year review.
And so we talked a little bit about the five-year review.
Well, before I do that, we did have a virtual public meeting.
It was held on March 3rd, 2021.
It was hosted by EPA, and EPA provided a site update in advance of that meeting for folks to look at.
I believe it was dated February 24th of 2020.
And the public meeting included a brief background of the site summary of the private well sampling program and updates of ongoing site investigation activities the virtual forum provided opportunities for participants to submit written questions and or expand on discussion topics so um want to go then again I'd like to discuss the five-year review before we go to 494 so a five-year review for those who don't know that's a requirement of the Superfund program when a site is on the national priority list after the remedy has been selected and, there is a requirement to do a review every five years to make sure that that remedy is still protective and that the site is properly understood to make that determination.
So EPA initiated its fifth five-year review, so the fifth time that a five- review is spent on for the coakley site in january of 2021 and that process really allows for as i said a periodic review for the effectiveness the remedial actions that are implemented at the site um they issued a report after completion of that review in September of 2021, so just this past fall.
And the five-year review process requires the review of the effectiveness of the regional actions that are implemented.
It includes interviews with community officials, residents living near the site, and other stakeholders.
It summarizes the actions that have been taken at the site during that previous review period since the last review, and it provides an assessment of the protectiveness of the current remedy at the site relative to human health and the environment, and it provides recommendations to make sure that the remedy remains protective for the long term.
And so based on a thorough review of the actions being taken and the data collected at the site, this past five-year review concluded that the remedy being implemented at the site is protective of human health and the environment.
And the reason that determination has been made is because it concluded that the remediation performed has addressed the contaminant disorders and that institutional controls and access controls are in place to prevent exposure to site sources and downgrading groundwater.
So the five-year review also made recommendations, as they usually do, for work that needs to be done to ensure that the remedy remains protective of human health and the environment in the long term.
And there were essentially four recommendations that were made in that review.
The first was to complete bedrock investigations to delineate extent of contamination in bedrock ground water.
And as well as the result is to determine the fate of transport PFAS compounds and site contaminant in water and determine if further action is warranted.
And of course that investigation has been completed.
We expect to report at the end of this year and we'll have more detailed discussions on that in the January meeting.
The second recommendation was to design and implement a background study, including sampling and analysis as necessary to determine if the concentrations of arsenic and manganese are reflective of background conditions or rather the result of mobilization due to the reducing conditions created by landfill.
It's important to understand we have a lot of landfills in the state, both solid waste and landfills that are closed.
We do typically, it's not uncommon to see elevated manganese and arsenic at those, in the groundwater surrounding those sites.
And the reason is that landfills typically have a lot of organic material.
As that organic material is broken down, reducing conditions are created in the landfill that actually mobilizes arsenic and manganese that are naturally occurring in the soils and rocks near the site.
But because of the change in chemistry, they can go from a solid state in the rock or in the soil to a dissolved state and increase concentration, as a result of increased concentrations in groundwater.
So the results of that study, so they want to evaluate this to see in this case whether the arsenic and manganese that's being seen at current levels is the result of background conditions because there are naturally occurring background concentrations of arsenic and manganese anywhere you look in groundwater in the state.
And then that will be used, so the results of that study will be used to assess, you know, how natural attenuation will occur at the site and the time to clean up for getting those arsenic and manganese concentrations where they need to be.
The third recommendation was to do continued sampling of onsite monitoring wells and area private wells, surface water sediment and stormwater runoff, including analysis for PFAS compounds to monitor trends and continue to compare current screening levels and established standards.
And then the fourth recommendation was to continue to evaluate the need for institutional and access controls for areas outside the current groundwater management zone based on plume delineation and future land use.
So clearly the results of the bedrock study are going to significantly help to inform a number of these recommendations.
So the COPIA group continues continues to be responsible for implementation of the remedy and these recommendations in the fifth five-year review with oversight by EPA and New Hampshire BES.
So Dave, the Cochlear Group has already responded.
they will be doing this, the arsenic and manganese testing, is that correct, or do we know?
I don't know if we've heard a specific response, but they don't have a choice.
They need to make it.
Okay.
Is that in the report?
Is that in the report available, by the way?
Yes.
It was issued, I believe, on September 24th of 2021.
And actually, this memo that I'll provide has some hot links in it to a lot of these documents that I've referenced.
So you'll actually see it.
It'll be very interactive where you can do something in particular you're interested in.
There's a link there.
You can click on that and see the document that supports it.
Okay.
And it'll tell us when Coakley has to respond or actually do these testing or I'm sure there's some kind of a timeline that they have to have a company.
Yeah, it may set out a schedule for that.
Certainly that would be an expectation that that would be.
That's what the agencies will be working with Cochley Landfill Group to figure out and make sure that those are implemented.
I don't know the specific schedule, but I'm sure there's one in there.
All right.
Thank you.
And then the last topic i wanted to discuss was um related to house bill 494 494 and the work to evaluate surface water quality and try to improve surface water quality in barry's brook so 494, in response to House Bill 494, the COG submitted a draft work plan for the treatment of surface water in Barry's Brook back in September of 2020.
And they conducted a pilot study during the fall of 2020 consistent with their work plan that they submitted.
And then they submitted a brief memo on the results of the pilot study in March of 2021.
And, you know, long story short, basically what they did is they put a bioabsorbent media into Barry's Brookok.
It did some work.
It turns out there's an area that conveys flow to the brook that was a really good location to try to put in some kind of treatment media because it's kind of like a shoot or a trough where the brook is more channelized.
It's very difficult when something is very dispersed, like wetland flow into a brook.
It's hard to figure out where to put treatment.
But they were able to identify, after correcting a lot of flow problems created by beaver over the years, they were able to get a lot of the flow from the brook that was basically channelized through this area on the site.
And they put in some bioavailable carbon.
It's basically, it's like granulated carbon, but it's somewhat different material that was in these mats.
And they tried to put that into, they tried to deploy that in this particular area of the brook to try to get flow through of the brook water through these treatment media in hopes of removing PFAS onto the media and which would hopefully result in lower concentrations of PFAS downstream of the media and the treatment system.
And that really was just a failure.
It did not work at all.
There was little or no impact to the surface water quality as a result of that.
So that really was unfortunate.
You know, it was really not a successful pilot study.
And so since completing that, the CochAnthro Group has entered into a contract with XDD Environmental to proceed with developing other treatment alternatives.
And XDD is to provide a report that suggests a more optimal remedial approach and identifies data gaps that will further refine treatability and pilot test plan.
pilot test plan and we expect to receive that report during the first quarter of 2022.
So that's not going to mean we're going to be going directly to some kind of pilot, but hopefully we're going to get some ideas that are a little better informed and a little bit more that certainly have a lot better chance of being successful and that will lead to a pilot at a future date that will result in you know a more successful treatment of the water in berries's Brook.
And that's unfortunately all I have on that.
That's where we're at until we get that report in the first quarter of 2022.
And I think that brings to a conclusion the top topics that I wanted to cover.
I'm happy to field any additional questions.
So, Mr.
Chairman, that timeline is, they've really kind of fallen off the timeline that was envisioned.
Thank you.
uh that timeline is they've really kind of fallen off the timeline that was envisioned in It is.
Is there any penalty being applied for the delay?
There was a large gap in the town of Greenland, which was very upset by that gap, which I represent and Representative Molloy represents.
Has DES been able to apply any penalty or any pressure since this is in statute?
We have not applied any penalty.
Anything we might do or be considering is not something we can discuss in the forum.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you for all that.
It's been very helpful.
Greenland is really eager to hear that report from the A.
And I think he said on January 24th, he said it was due.
In what form will that presentation be made will there be a presentation or when we'll be able to talk Kelsey here we did the bedrock investigation report is due at the end of this month.
And we will we do expect to have a presentation discussion for that at our january 24th meeting that was epa that's well it's the bedrock investigation report prepared by clg okay um that that this is This is the culmination of a number of years' work to investigate the deep bedrock aquifer there.
That's a separate matter from Barry's Brooke.
What I – and perhaps I misspoke, but the report that XDD is due to submit – you know, CLG's consultant, XDD, is working on developing, really, and I don't know.
data gaps.
And anybody who works in this business knows when you talk about identifying data gaps.
The next step on that is we've got to get that data before we can do the next thing.
So that report is due in the first quarter of 2022, which means by the end of March of 2022.
I don't know specifically when it will come in, but that's not something I don't believe.
It's realistic to think we're going to be in a position or be prepared to discuss that at the January 24th meeting.
So I just want to be clear.
Yeah, I want to make sure I'm clear too.
Bedrock, the EPA bedrock.
24th that's our right the bedrock investigation report is due to be submitted toDS by CLG by the end of this month.
Okay.
And that will give us, we certainly would expect it will give us time to prepare, you know, a workman-like presentation and be prepared for a discussion of the results of that at the January 24th meeting of this commission.
Thank you.
Chair.
Yeah.
So if you're concerned about your some of the folks in your town they will be able to tune into that presentation.
This committee is my understanding, correct?
Yes.
That would be very important.
So I'm happy to say I mean my understanding is that XCD is a very capable firm.
And I think that they're working on it because they're trying to take a very easy sort of critical look at it and look at what was done and why it didn't work.
And figure out what do we need to know and what and we need to design to make it work so i don't i don't think it's a simple matter but it's something they are to work on and one one more question i'm uh i'm new new to the commission but one of the things that I'm curious about too is in addition to looking at treating the surface water, the problem is actually the contamination that gets into the surface water.
So what is actually being done at this point to try to identify the sources of contamination and to potentially isolate and remove them?
Well, there is work continuing looking at whether, you know, the lion's share of these contaminants are coming from the actual groundwater that's impacted by the landfill or whether they're actually coming from stormwater runoff that occurs and essentially water that interacts with the cap materials but not necessarily the network is still continuing it's not really clear on what the apportionment is it may well be a combination.
And I think that, you know, as time goes on here and we have a better understanding of this, there may well be an alternate way to area.
So technically, from a technical standpoint, pumping and treating all of that groundwater could be difficult thank you what's your full name sir again it's David Muse and the US.
Yeah, I just wanted to make sure that the masks always throw me off.
Okay.
So thank you.
Thank you Mr.
Muse.
Senator Schumer.
Mike, there were two other.
I'm sorry.
I thought you were calling me Mike.
He's Mike.
Mike's Mike.
So there are major surface water effluents coming off of Coakley.
There's Bailey's Brook, and there is Little River.
As part of the last EPA sampling, CLG sampling, did we get any results?
I know that you basically said today, wells, that there was no evidence of migration to plume but did we see any effluent in little river or bailey's brook um since that has been a concern i think the identified Aquarian well was at five or six that had to be shut down.
That turned out to be a car wash facility that was illegally contaminating groundwater in its region.
But did we see any contamination of the F1 in those two brooks or streams?
MR.
Thanks for the question.
There is data that – for both of those surface water systems that I believe that there have been detections, but I don't believe that, and again, I'm not up to speed on all the specifics on that, but my understanding is that what we used to believe, that those any detections were resulting in any adverse impacts to drinking water or drinking water wells.
Okay.
Can you follow up?
Just a comment.
Can we get the latest results of those all the wells and effluent and surface water treatment?
And the second part, the second question is one, since this is a commission that although it's focused on what's happening in the seacoast, but we need to learn from some of this, has Has there been statewide testing of capped landfills to see if the capped or lined landfills to see if there is now a leachate of PFAS coming off of those linings and what is the impact on those communities or capped landfills do we have in the state and do we know whether there's been any contamination from each eight of those?
We're on the order of 150 closed landfills in the state.
Most of them are formerly owned and operated solid waste landfills.
We don't necessarily have groundwater monitoring in every single one of those landfills because in some cases they weren't required but in most cases we do and where we do have groundwater monitoring we have required that p fast testing be conducted and i can tell you that p fast has been almost uniformly detected in the impact of the groundwater from those you know the The waste that went into those landfills almost uniformly had some signature of PFAS in it.
So we do have a number, I don't think it's a large number, but a number of landfills where there have been impacts that have required that they look at potentially to nearby drinking water wells.
In most cases, we see a PFAS signature in the monitoring wells associated with landfills, but we have not had impacts to drinking water further afield.
But there are some examples of where that's occurred, and those towns are taking responsibility and doing the necessary additional monitoring or, in some cases, providing for some treatment of, you know, point of entry treatment for drinking water wells that have been impacted.
Thanks.
You're welcome.
Thank you.
Mr.
Wimsatt, just thank you again for being here, by the way.
I appreciate the information you'll be providing us.
Specific to the PFOSA that you spoke of earlier that was found to be sampled and be done by this, I don't know what company.
I don't know if you said the company.
No, I didn't, I didn't say it.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, you did.
Not found to be appropriate and then another test took place?
Yes, that's correct.
Okay, that being said, have there been any, and this is a question, is there any investigation the sample preparation that should be or are being used for the sampling that takes place?
Well, there are a number of specific EPA methods that have been developed, drinking water and groundwater, for PFAS.
And we would expect the labs to follow those.
or differences between labs, that's just the reality and we've found that more contaminants because again we're working at the outer reaches of capabilities here where we've got labs and kudos to them.
They've, you know, in a relatively short period of time, they've gone from very high detection limits for these compounds down to being able to pretty reliably detect and report and quantify concentrations down around the one-part petroleum level.
It's remarkable what's occurred.
But as far as those labs, as you can imagine, the industry, the laboratories, they are working off of nationally approved methods.
The Office of Research and Development at EPA in the early going here was working extensively on developing methods, you know, in the research environment for how to detect low concentrations of a number of these compounds.
And they've shared that information with the lab industry.
And the lab industry has just, you know, taken to get those new methods.
But keep in mind, DES is not in a position to be dictating to a lab how they do their work.
Those are national standards that they're using.
And as your guidance then, knowing what took place, that the test that said yes, and then when it was looked at again by another source, it was found that it was not PFOSA, was not present.
What confidence level should we be looking at when we have to do our report in six months relative to test methodologies?
I mean, does it require legislative action or rules or funding for our DES to ensure that the test methodology meets our together criteria?
No, I don't think that it requires that.
I think that what we have to understand is that you've got laboratories here in the state and outside of the state that are sampling and other analyzing and thousands of samples.
And every once in a while, something's going to go wrong.
And so when it does go wrong, we have methods available to try to run those issues to ground.
We resample and we run it with a couple of labs and we try to figure out the answer.
And the report, the memo that I'll provide you does have some links to the supporting documents of that.
So information in some greater detail that i've been able to provide you today uh will be available to commission members to take a look at if they have concerns okay thank you follow up by senator shim uh quick uh mike um so you have two specimens one that showed detection and a follow-up that did not.
How do we know which one is real?
I mean, do we need a third?
Do we need some kind of understanding with PFOSA?
You know, I don't want to go down this road too far because I'm not an expert on what happened here But all the information supporting information will be provided And if you want to have further discussion of us at the January meeting I can have people here who have been closer to what was done here because I what I don't want to do is do this an injustice by my You know, I mean I always tell people in my in my particular position I know a lot of stuff a mile wide and sometimes only an inch deep.
A lot of times from that, but sometimes only an inch deep.
So what I don't want to do is try to give you an answer just to make you happy here.
And I think what you're looking for is maybe a little more detailed.
Yeah, I think in a written where we know there's PFOSA in Coakley in the landfill itself.
Right.
We now have one of two samples showing PFOSA in a drinking water well.
So it's my understanding that the follow-up work made it clear that that was not a real result.
But I won't be the one to tell you.
At the January 24th meeting, you can follow that up, and we can get you someone who can give you a more detailed answer.
Also, I think if you're able to look at the interactions that went on with regard to this, you'll be able to see and assess for yourself whether you're satisfied with the analysis.
Thank you.
Before I recognize a representative here, just to see you know for your and assess for yourself whether you're satisfied with the with the analysis thank you before i recognize uh representative uh just to get your guidance how how should i put that on the agenda when you said so do we have a particular person that we want to have speak to this specific subject um well why don't we this?
Let me provide this memo with its associated documents.
Okay.
And I think, I don't know that it needs to necessarily, it's up to the commission if they want to make it an agenda item, but it may be that the commission or if they're not, they can certainly bring it up at the next meeting.
Rep.
Abrami?
Tom, I'm looking at you when I make this analogy.
So in health care, there are many, many drugs that are on the market, many more drugs every day on the market.
And the big issue within health care is drug interactions.
And you only know what you know.
And I'm sure the drug companies are doing the testing that doesn't interact harmfully with another drug.
It sounds like I'm using that as an analogy because it seems like the same situation here.
Is we know what we know, but I guess we're finding out there's more interactions of compounds that we learn about every day.
And that could trigger a positive test that was caused by one compound and another compound interacting with each other.
So I can understand how that can happen using the drug interaction issue.
So you say you're going to bring somebody in that's maybe able to speak more to this, how this happens?
Yeah, we'll be prepared to answer that question.
Right.
At the 24th meeting.
That seem like a reasonable analogy.
And again, these documents may answer that for you, but in the event they don't, we'll plan to have someone who can speak.
I understand there are a lot of people smarter than me who are working on these individual things.
And I'm not sure I can get you the analyst from the lab to come to this meeting, but I can certainly get someone from one of the agencies, either DES or EPA, that's more for them if this was run to ground.
I'll be happy to do that.
Brett Molloy.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Staying on this PFO-SA question, these tests do cost money, correct?
Yes.
Okay.
So when the CLG had that done, they have to pay for that?
Yes, that's correct.
I don't know how much that is and I'm not asking about that particularly but and I have been to a Coakley landfill group meeting admittedly but what is what would be in that process and unfair question to ask you too but you see a test come in what's the process to go oh, wait a minute, we want to do that again.
It's, where does that stop?
What I'm getting at here is I'm looking for something to test this to finally say that there's nothing wrong or I'm just, I don't know how that process works, how they decide to test that again.
So the request to sample again was made by EPA in a letter to the CLG on March 10, 2021.
And in this memo, there's a hot link to that, so you'll be able to look at that letter and read it.
You know, obviously, I think the agencies wanted to know or not, but I think there was I would imagine there was plenty of incentive on the part of CLG to understand it as well.
So we did not, as far as I know, we had no pushback when we requested that this be done.
This is not an uncommon scenario.
When you're doing hundreds of samples at dozens of sites, you're going to get data that doesn't make sense sometimes.
Sometimes we run it to ground and it's real.
Other times we run it to ground and it's not.
We always want to run it to ground to make sure we understand what we're really looking at.
Mr.
Muse.
One additional question.
I'm curious about how PFOSA was actually initially detected.
What it says to me is that we're looking for other PFAS compounds in addition to those spores.
And what I'm curious about is how many additional compounds are we testing for?
Yeah, I'm not sure the answer for this particular site.
There are, you know, a number of analyses that are, you know, they've changed over time.
Initially, we only had about nine, and then we were up to 16.
A lot of routine analyses identify analyses identify I believe somewhere on the order of 20 or 25 PFAS compounds.
But I don't know the answer to that but I can find out for you how many are being reported.
Are you aware of the tap water test that the city of Portsmouth did where PFPRA was detected in city water?
Yes, I am.
One of the things that I thought was interesting about that particular test was that 70 different chemicals were tested for.
The other thing that's interesting is nobody seems to have any information regarding the health impacts of PFPRA or even a really good idea of how it actually gets into the environment, which sort of tells us that, you know, to a large extent, a lot of the work that we're doing really seems to be just scratching the surface of the problem.
Yeah, what I understand about PFPRA is that it has been detected globally.
It's been detected, I think, in Arctic ice.
So it's across the globe.
There are some, and again, I'm not an expert on this, but I've talked to some staff at the agency that say that it may be sort of associated with, in terms of the time that they believe they started detecting it, with some changes in some refrigerants associated with, as you know, fluorocarbons are associated with use as refrigerants, and some changes that occurred a few decades ago with respect to the chemistry for commonly used refrigerants, and it may be associated with that.
But you're right.
Let's be honest.
There are thousands of PFAS compounds, and we're dealing with it.
We've currently got standards for four of them, but we get a lot of data.
We learn new things every day about PFAS, and we continue to watch and learn and try to explore and try to understand as much as we can about it.
But it's difficult because, again, the number of compounds for which there is a reasonable body of research to evaluate toxicity is very, very small at this point.
Thank you.
MR.
Okay, just two final comments.
We need to speak with Ms.
Hammond next.
Senator Sherman.
SEN.
I just wanted to remind the Commission that PFAS is still being manufactured and still being used.
We still have it in nationally required or federally required firefighting.
We were able to eliminate it from other state foams.
So this isn't going away.
It's just changing the compounds that may be actually more difficult to filter that would require resins rather than charcoal, which is Portsmouth is having to deal with that at the Hazenwell.
I think their program there requires a very complex and sophisticated filtering system.
And then you have to figure out what to do with the filter.
So scratching the surface is a beautiful understatement for the impact that this is going to have on the state of New Hampshire.
And one comment is Portsmouth is in a very interesting position of actually being a responsible party when it comes to the Coakley landfill, but also our residents have been very much a victim of PFAS contamination when it comes to what went on over at Pease.
So I think in a lot of ways we're in a pretty unique position to sort of see this thing from a number of different perspectives, and that's one of the things I want to try to add to this body as we go forward with our work.
Thank you.
One last question for you, Mr.
Wimsett.
It's something that Mr.
Mewes brought up.
And actually, 1.4 dioxin that was found, I believe you said in the beginning, you talked about dioxin when you first made a comment.
The question was whether CLG was actually being compelled to test for dioxin and if not, why not?
Mike, going on that, I just wanted to ask, as I recall, that was found in testing of the fish, flesh testing?
Do I recall that correctly?
Your comment there, but in going forward, is the dioxin continuing to be part of our search factors for contaminants or not?
I wanted to see what your guidance was.
Well, to be clear, we talked about two different chemicals here for a moment.
Dioxin, that's D-I-O-X-I-N, is one group of chemicals.
One for dioxane is an entirely different chemical.
Oh, excuse me.
That's me.
I was always focusing on the one for.
I just want to make sure we're all talking about the same thing.
I'll be honest with you.
I'm not sure what the past history on dioxin analysis is associated with the landfill, and I will make sure we get some information for you on that.
Yes, clarification for that next meeting.
So it's 1,4-Dioxin.
No, no, 1,4-Dioxane.
E-N-E.
1,4-Dioxane is a ultra-organic compound that was detected in two drinking water wells and is currently near the site and is currently being treated in those wells.
There's point of entry treatment on both of those wells to treat the 1,4-Dioxane.
And it is a contaminant of concern at the site.
It's a carcinogen.
Yeah.
That's correct.
Right.
And dioxin is still a chemical that's being tested for.
Yeah, I believe it's been tested for in the past.
I don't know that it's part of a current battery of testing.
We don't typically find it in groundwater because it's not particularly mobile, but I will get you the details on that.
all right thank you very much all right thank you very much mr wormstack you're welcome thank you and look forward to that documentation just to have a focus point if you could like just send it all to me yes and then i will make sure it gets to our to our commission members and we'll have that I will do that today.
And it'll be out tonight by me.
Okay.
Fair enough.
Thank you very, very much.
You're welcome.
Thank you.
Okay.
So I'd like to recognize Ms.
Whitney Hammond, who's very kind to put us on her schedule today.
She's been multitasking in this room before this committee started.
Thank you.
But I thank you very much.
And this is in reference to the cancer registry and specific to what put the commission together as the cancer investigation.
So looking for your update and guidance.
Sure.
And I don't know where there are some new members.
I just kind of jotted down a couple of notes about the timeline and a little bit of the history.
It won't take long, but just to kind of give people that background, it might be um so uh and actually yeah so i'm whitney hammond i'm the administrator for the chronic disease prevention and screening section at the division of public health and that includes the cancer program for our agency and i've been in that position now for 10 years so back in 2014 we received some initial contacts from community members in the Seacoast area saying that they had observed cases of cancers that were unusual or of the same type, and they were really interested in working with us as the department to think about coordinating a response to that concern.
We did a lot of kind of back and forth in figuring out what our approach would be in terms of an analysis, and eventually released a report in 2016, so early 2016, that indicated there were higher than expected numbers of a few pediatric cancer types in the seacoast area.
None of those cancer types that were found had a sort of clear known environmental risk factor that would cause them.
So in some cases, bladder cancer is a good example.
We know that there is evidence to show a connection between arsenic and bladder cancer.
And so in a case where you might have a higher than expected number of bladder cancers, you could then kind of make an effort to look at differences in exposure between people with bladder cancer and then what we call controls or people that do not have bladder cancer but might have similar characteristics.
So in the case where we didn't have that kind of a known environmental exposure, the department worked to do what's called a case series, and that was really trying to look at people who had the different types of cancers, and in this case it was rhabdomyrosarcoma and plural, I can't hear, PPB.
Plural pulmonary glaucoma.
Thank you.
And so we cast a kind of broad net.
We worked with Vermont, Maine, and Massachusetts, and we really developed a pretty broad case definition for people who had a certain level of exposure to the seacoast, so just of seacoast towns, but people who may have spent time vacationing there.
And so the case series was really looking at, can we find any kind of association, shared exposure between people, able to find any kind of common association between any cases that would allow us to take the next step in the response to community concerns, which would be a case control study.
So one of the things we did commit to doing just so that we were, you know, continuing to monitor cancer in the area was working with our partners at Dartmouth who operate the New Hampshire State Cancer Registry.
That's the data system that we rely on for understanding cancer in communities.
And so we have an agreement with them where they inform us that basically the second they get any RMS or PPB cancer cases in the state, we were alerted and so as of you know today there have been no new cases since um the original report was published so there's nothing in terms of like doing those calculations that get at what's called a standardized incidence ratio that's the sort of ultimate that's the number that is was included in the report that was higher than expected um but because we have no new cases there's really nothing new to calculate so that's that's the high level overview and the update is sort of there isn't anything really new in terms of cases and i'm happy to answer questions just i want to put some uh the large word that yeah i'll let him say it again yeah what's the acronym for that ppb that's it yeah ppb that's easier yeah on the serious side of PPB, the study was,, you said?
Is that the benchmark from the study you referred to?
We published the report in 2016, and my guess would be that based on that, the data was through 2014.
There tends to be a two-year delay in what we consider to be our data being complete.
Okay.
And my question, using that, then your guidance on that being the benchmark, there's no, there has been no PPB cases reported since then?
And as well as no RMS.
That's the other Rhabdomyosarcoma, the other cancer that was found to be higher than expected.
Okay.
Outside of those two diseases, was there any other cancer, specifically cancer incidences that have been recorded?
So we collect information on all cancers diagnosed in New Hampshire residents.
So there would absolutely, you know, and again, if you're looking at all age groups, have been additional cancers diagnosed in those areas.
But we have not been monitoring anything beyond those two types of cancers that were found to be higher than expected.
Okay, Senator Sherman.
Yeah, and Whitney and I go way back now at this point, and thank you for all the work you've done on this.
Just to clarify, the results of the April 2017 case series, as hard as everybody worked to get enough people on board, that didn't have enough power statistically to say there is no connection.
All it could say is that we couldn't identify a connection based on that study.
So the second part of that, I think you did do a query of the registry after Rep.
Mesmer or some others brought up the issue of pediatric brain cancers, which were – there were a large number in Portsmouth and Rye.
and I don't think it went down as far as Seabrook, but I know Northampton had some, and right now Hampton has at least two children with, I don't know if it's a glioblastoma, but one of the lessons from that study, I think you were at the presentation, or somebody from DHHS was, was that these are multiple different types of brain cancers, and we had a neuro-oncologist who was saying that, a pediatric neuro-oncologist at the meeting saying that even though there was a fairly large number, they are all different.
You need to look at all of them individually rather than as brain cancer in children.
Has there been a look back because of the degree of concern, or can we do a look back at probably the, I think it wasn't at a 12-town area that we originally identified rather than the five towns or 10-town area when you first started your analysis.
That included Seabrook, went all the way down the seacoast and then back in a couple of towns Just to just to update The pediatric concern about brain cancer I I know we were marching in the holiday parade in Hampton and the young boy I think was he was honored with the marshal, and he's suffering from that as well.
So it's just if we could get an update on those cancers, that would be great.
And just to clarify, so the different types of brain cancers in particular, or I think what I recall from maybe 2017 was we might have done SIR calculations Thank you.
of brain cancers in particular?
Or I think what I recall from maybe 2017 was we might have done SIR calculations for pediatric cancers and used, we have sort of, I think it's around 23 sites that we usually look at, you know, so things like kidney, lung.
Are you looking for an update on like all sites or specifically brain?
I think it was specifically BRAIN.
You've already done PPV and RMS, so that would be really helpful.
That's what I keep seeing over and over again.
Portsmouth seems to have the lion's share, but they're also the largest town.
Yeah, that's something that we should be able to do up through hopefully 2019.
So again, we have that two-year delay, but we can look.
Right.
And one follow-up?
Yes, follow-up.
And one other thing.
When we talked about pancreatic cancer and breast cancer and all those others back then, The benchmark that DHHS used for comparison was other parts of the state that are similar.
Is there, would it be more useful to use national data as a comparison rather than state data to see if there's an increased incidence?
So we get that question a lot, and we can do that.
So we can do both even, and look.
It's sort of kind of – I was struck by Mike Wimsatt's description of the more you sample, the more you find.
So we can do all sorts of calculations, and there's going to be probably some – you know, the more times you do calculations, the more times you're going to potentially have a signal that could just be based on math and, you know, probability, but we could look into that.
I'd want to consult with our folks at Dartmouth who did recently do a reanalysis of pediatric cancers compared to the rest of the U.S.
and did find differences in terms of when you start to compare us to other states, you have to be able to adjust for things like age, race, ethnicity, because those things do impact cancer.
But yeah, let me, I can look into using the rest of the U.S.
Yeah, just to make a follow-up point on that, for example, if you look at the Seacoast rate of breast cancer, we know New Hampshire is one of the highest rates of breast cancers in the country.
Right.
So looking at the rest of New Hampshire isn't going to be particularly helpful unless it's even higher.
So that's why finding a benchmark that's more reflective of sort of the national might be more meaningful.
Yep.
That makes sense.
Thank you.
Repubrami.
Thank you for your presentation.
So Dartmouth Cancer Registry, my understanding is the hospitals have tumor registrars that will report abstract, leave the cancers, and report them to Dartmouth, to the central location, which in this case in this state it's Dartmouth.
So today, when they're doing that, they will say, and when it comes to pediatric cancer, I would imagine that a lot of children will be treated perhaps at Chad or other more centralized, more larger facilities that have specialists for pediatric cancer.
So I'm assuming that they will, though, document the location where that person lives and all of that?
Okay.
I was trying to understand the data and how it flows.
Yeah, go ahead.
Why don't you answer that?
And I'll have a follow-up.
Yeah.
I can get more information or the specifics, but from what I understand in New Hampshire, I would say around maybe 80% of children with cancer end up being diagnosed and treated in Massachusetts.
And then the remaining 20% probably are treated at Dartmouth.
But we do have data sharing agreements with all of, it's seven different states, but we absolutely do a lot of data sharing with Massachusetts.
So we would have that information.
One major limitation with the cancer registry is the address that we have is the address that's provided to the hospital in terms of, you know, where that individual lives at the time of diagnosis.
And it doesn't capture anything about residential history.
Right.
So, you know, you could absolutely be counting someone as a resident of, let's say, Rye who had just moved there the week before they were diagnosed.
Now, when it comes to analyzing the data, to me it's a big multivariate problem.
I mean, there's so many variables that you have to control for to try to isolate.
Is this variable really causing the cancer?
Can you just speak to that real quick?
Yeah, it's a great way to describe it.
So the state has a protocol that we follow.
It's completely informed by the CDC's protocol around how do you respond to a suspected cancer cluster.
And the part, sort of the second, so the first phase is to just collect a lot of information and understand what types of cancers are of concern.
If it seems to sort of start to fit with the definition of a cancer cluster, which is one of the things I think most often people are not aware of is that for a cluster, it really should be a specific type of cancer because we know you know cancer is not one disease it doesn't have one risk factor so probably 99 of the calls I get and respond to is just me providing education about that because you know certainly in a state with an older population we're going to see a lot more cancer than some other states so the cdc recommends using this standardized incidence ratio calculation which is when you take the data that we have in the registry account for those sorts of things like residential history or even exposure and to to do this calculation of looking at what are the number of cases that we're seeing for a specific type of cancer, and how does that compare to what the number of cases would be if you looked like this other population that should be reasonably similar.
And that's to Dr.
Sherman's sort of suggestion around, do you use the rest of New Hampshire as a reference population, or do you use the rest of the United States?
And there's, again, it's sort of, it's this delicate sort of decision making, but ultimately the goal would be if you get an SIR that's higher than you would expect, it's not that it's going to tell you, oh, this is related to this known exposure.
It doesn't give you any information about the cause, but it's really just a signal to then consider going to the next step, which would be the more rigorous case control study.
And again, in the case of the Seacoast Cancer Cluster, we weren't able to do that next step of a case control study until we even had an idea of what might be the common exposure.
So that was why we did the case series where we were just even trying to see could we come up with a plausible hypothesis to then test with a case control study.
I just want to make sure I understand.
So the conclusion was, and I know, Tom, you were trying to express this, is that we couldn't find a positive correlation.
I won't even use correlation of cause and effect.
But that doesn't rule out that there's – is that what you're saying?
Yeah.
And really what we were looking at, because Dr.
Sherman's point is exactly right.
Just because you don't find something doesn't mean that there wasn't something or that, you know.
But what we were really seeking to do is see if we could even test a hypothesis and that just from the case series, there wasn't even something in common that we could use to then define what a case was for a case control study.
Thank you.
Whitney, I do remember actually talking.
I don't think I talked to you, but somebody at the department, there was a little girl who had grown up exposed to peas.
They moved to Northern Mass, and she developed RMS.
I have lost touch with her mom.
You remember we did, or you did a really great job of checking out Southern Maine, Essex County, and that area in Massachusetts.
Has there been – is there any way to check with those to see if they've seen any more cases of RMS or PPV?
One of the things that I know we discussed is that there was a fairly common exposure.
everyone who tested positive, they had some level of exposure to PFAS, but I don't believe with those two diseases nationally there has been any association with PFAS at this point.
Again, the numbers are so small it's hard to get the data.
But I was just wondering if we could check with those two states.
And just to answer Representative Abrami's question, we actually get really great data from Portland, where Maine Med is, and from Boston, big children's and all those.
So if they live in New Hampshire, we get the data.
but it does account for that two-year lag because you know there's just time of reporting yeah we can we can absolutely do that we're we are a pretty small tight-knit community in northern new england so they i would suspect they would let us know if they had um had any new cases but i can proactively see if that's the case be great thanks mr muse one one additional question um um something i've been thinking a little bit about is is the the case of a place like pease air force base, which obviously was the source of a lot of contamination.
But you also have a lot of people who work there and who sent their kids to school there who may have lived as far away as an hour away from the base.
So there's a situation where you can have a source of contamination that affects a group of people in a very specific geographic area, but then they go and disperse.
So I guess my question is, when you're dealing with something like that, how do you, how do you, can you even detect a cancer cluster?
Or should we be looking at things, broader, broader things like the fact that we have the highest rate of breast cancer in the nation, one of the highest rates for prostate cancer.
I'm trying to get a handle on maybe how to kind of come at this problem with, I guess, maybe more effectiveness and maybe more impact.
so for the case series that we did, which was really like a call for people that might be able to help us then identify something in common that would be a signal to look into, we did broadly – so it's very unusual that a health department would define a case the way that we did, which was to be as inclusive as possible.
And that was really based on that RMS and PPP are very uncommon cancers, just even nationally.
So we knew the numbers would be very, very small.
So we did try to cast a net in terms of our case definition that would include an individual who maybe had been you know like diagnosed with rms but had worked in port smith but lived elsewhere so our definition was i believe that they had up to 30 days worth of you know time in those the towns that we you know defined as seacoast over the course of i I wanna say it was even 10 years.
So that was an effort to not just capture people who had a place of residence that would be in that region.
And still we didn't, I can't remember how many cases we even had respond to our survey.
Yeah, 12 sounds right.
I mean, it's a very very small number well i'm sorry there were 12 subjects but only a handful like four or five actually replied to the survey yeah um sure i understand that i just want to follow up on that.
So four or five, and that was more detailed questions that were asked.
Yeah, looking at- The chairman lifestyle, where they were, where they lived before and all that.
Exactly.
Yep, where their parents worked.
Okay, Senator Chairman.
One comment to your point, David, is that ACSDR and the Carson, Rachel Carson both have studies looking at fees and PFAS thanks to the pressure that has been putting on to get the funding, the national funding.
So those are federally, the ATSDR, I believe it's under ATSDR, is ongoing.
The problem they're having is the same problem we have, which is the number of participants.
With all those people exposed, they're not getting a robust participation.
And the other problem that I have with that study is that it's a one-point-in-time study rather than a longitudinal overtime study, which, as I think most of us recognize, a lot of these contaminants, the impact is something that you see over, sometimes over decades.
I don't know.
I think most of us recognize a lot of these contaminants, the impact of something that you see sometimes over decades.
One of the big issues with PFAS is testicular cancer and that doesn't even, the risk doesn't even go up until the boy has gone through tuberculosis.
So these are decades-long problems that are uncovered.
right do you have anything further at this point, Ms.
Hammond?
No, I don't.
Okay, I just have some guidance from you from my standpoint.
And from the beginning of the commission, since I've been a member here, I asked the question specifically of your predecessor, who was Dr.
Chan.
And that was, there wasn't a person who wasn't interested in addressing pediatric cancer or the RMS and et cetera that we've been talking about.
But I have a mantra that says, let's do it while we're young.
And the key here is, I want to ask you this, is there anything you can recommend, not like right now, but could you put something together or a recommendation for our meeting on the 24th on actions that we as a state should be doing regarding the science of or how broad our investigation should be, like Dr.
Sherman, Senator Sherman has talked about, in determining is there a cause and effect, and not just the seacoast, but in our state, for these cancers, and should we be doing something in addition that needs, again, legislative action or funding from a state level so that we can make substantive determinations on what to do, not just on what the commission is focusing on, but it's also from a broader state.
There's other contaminant committees that are meeting and if there's a cooperative collaboration to achieve a consensus on action, Steve, we can get – I'd like to ask if you could have maybe a comment – not a comment, a statement of what we should be doing for our next meeting that we could then discuss as we prepare for June 22 what the recommendations would be as a product of the meetings we've had.
That would be great.
I can definitely do that.
Okay.
I just have – Senator Sherman.
We did discuss this in past commissions.
I can't remember if it was this commission or environmentally triggered, but we actually put in a request.
One of the big gaps that we have in New Hampshire is in DHHS they just don't have the manpower of the funding to do this.
And I filed a bill with the commission supporting it.
You might have even been on it back in 2019 to really fill out the ranks of DHHS so they could do some of this investigating to understand the You know, pediatric breast, esophageal, we're seeing a ton of pancreatic and cholangiocarcinoma in the seacoast and stratum area.
And they've looked at the registry and they don't see that pancreatic cancer or the biliary cancers are at higher than expected.
But one of the gaps that we identified with these commissions is that, and we can always come back and revisit that, and I think the next budget year will be 2023.
But it might be something for us to think about.
Maybe, Whitney, you could talk about that gap that we identified.
Yes.
Yeah, I can definitely do that.
Okay.
So that you are now formally noticed, we want you to be here on the 24th.
Sure.
Maybe not here, but it will be a location that will have full interactive communication.
Okay.
That sounds great.
Anything for the gentleman?
For Ms.
Hammond?
Okay.
Thank you.
We thank you very much for your time.
So next on our agenda was a discussion of actions going forward.
Now, and then the recommendations recommendations, I mean, we have Mr.
Wimsatz, part of the committee.
And beyond what we've already discussed, is there anything further that we're going to have the update on the bedrock, which is what will provide us the information we need to have an informative guide on what our recommendations for action should be, specifically to the seacoast, for the commission's target.
But also, one thing I brought up personally myself is, this is, I think it's more about our state of New Hampshire as well, on the standards that we set, in terms of dealing with landfills and water protection around them.
Because I recall, again, the previous expertise that we've had here and the guidance from them was the testing done in Berries Brook and from Coakley, the landfill itself in Coakley, going to Berries Brook and the other one here, Little River, all in this.
This was what we had provided to us by our Department of Environmental Services.
The comment that was made repeatedly was the testing being done, and the response was it does not rise to the level of treatment.
And what I asked at that time was then what should we be doing in anticipation?
Remember there was the surface treatment of pumping water out around the Coakley and then putting it right back in after treatment.
And that was not moving forward.
And I did ask CLG, and I know we're live on this, I asked CLG to participate today, but there was not a response on what their input could be on this as part of this effort.
But going forward is there has not been an identified function that says, here's the contamination and hit the remediation to be done Based on the testing that we have so far that was testified here so this thing going forward and asking mr.
Wimpsett's important guidance is What are recommendations would be a map to the bedrock?
This is from the bedrock testing if we could have recommendation not if we need recommendations for this Commission to then present to our to the state on what our action should be with the 37 jurisdiction being the EPA and our DS not just it's not and again no longer it's about just the seacoast but it's for the state of New New Hampshire.
But that's my bias and what I've learned here in the last almost three years.
So that being said, we would have on our agenda the bedrock report, having further information and guidance from Ms.
Hammond on cancer registry study and what we need to do for resources.
But beyond that, what else should we be focusing on so there's preparation in time for substantive information to be provided to the Commission?
Please.
Let me ask this general question now Senator Sherman, you're on several other groundwater contamination commissions.
There's a series of these commissions.
I just want to make sure that we're not overlap.
Well, a little overlap is okay, but I want to make sure that we're not reproducing something that another commission is doing.
I know we had this conversation last year.
Is there something unique that we should be doing that these other commissions aren't doing?
Yeah, thanks for the question.
I, especially after today and hearing from Mike and Whitney, we are doing something that's very different from the other commissions.
There's always overlap.
You know, we're working on drinking water, groundwater.
We're doing source water protection.
That has a lot to do with PFAS.
That was where my question about other landfills, thinking across the state.
I know Senator Gray has a landfill in his area.
And so just making sure that we've got our finger on the pulse of what we learn out of here and extrapolating it statewide.
But what we've talked about today, no other commission I sit on has really focused on.
So at least in the near term, I think that this is really important.
And one the things that we've done since this is the Seacoast Cancer Cluster is keeping an eye on cancer rates in the Seacoast.
And then also, the legislature has really asked for a commitment from the EPA and DES on what we've learned coming out of Coakley.
There really is no other legislative body that's monitoring that.
To that end, what I was thinking is when the CLG report on the surface water, which specifically the legislature demanded that that surface water be remediated, we should here maybe have a meeting after that report's available, Mike, and have CLG here.
They've come to this before and talk about have DES, CLG, XTD, and anyone else who's expert in that and talk about what they're going to do to meet the legislature's demand for remediation of that surface water.
Just for the new members of the commission, Barry's Brook is critical because it flows into Little Harbor and then into the Viscataqua and into the ocean.
So the potential for right now, we have no surface water standards nationally for PFAS and correct me if I'm wrong, Mike.
Michigan, I believe, is the only state that's really tackled this.
And...
for PFAS, and correct me if I'm wrong, Mike, Michigan, I believe, is the only state that's really tackled this.
And yet, this is a constant flow.
And the Berriesbrook watershed is just an absolutely spectacular, beautiful, pristine watershed.
If you've never been down to look at it on Sagamore or Bracket, that area down near Odeorn.
People are fishing in it and as a result of the work of this commission, there's now a catch and release from the fisheries because they actually tested fish samples and they found some contamination.
So it's critically important for the state of New Hampshire, our fishing industry, our recreation industry, that we get this right.
And there's no one else, to your question, there's no one else or no other commission that I sit on that really is tackling this issue.
And we'll continue in the direction with the guidance of our DES, and we'll see what we learn from the EPA report that comes through.
A question to put out again, because there's another acronym that's come our way, which is PFOSA.
I have PFAS and PFOA down.
Now it's OSA.
Should we have or is there a person that's available that could speak to us with expertise specific to that contaminant?
I will have someone come to the next meeting ready to talk about that.
Thank you.
Maybe also the one that David mentioned that's in Portsmouth, PFPRA.
Is that Dr.
Ali?
Is he still our toxicologist?
Dr.
Patali, his name has changed, is our toxicologist.
We don't know.
We would not.
It would be a short conversation, and we don't know a lot about PFPRA.
But if that's the will of the commission, then I can talk to Dr.
Patalee and see if he can come.
Well, he's a wonderful speaker.
He would be great.
I do want to note that we do have the bedrock investigation, and my guess is that would consume a lot of the oxygen in the room.
So I just want to provide whatever the commission's will is, but be aware that if we have too many topics, it may dilute the main event, which I think is the bedrock investigation.
Right.
That is what's to come.
So yes, because the target for the 24th is the bedrock.
again the update from Ms.
Hammond.
Within that context, it's answering the additional questions that could be coming up with the acronyms that we have with what that testing will show from the bedrock testing.
So but it's the focus on those two primary items for the 24th right and then when we have our discussion after what we learned from the bedrock test statements is then and we meet in February is that then we'll extrapolate from there is what specifically do we do without the further expertise do we need to have to come in to testify for us.
Just to be clear, I would need to know if you want Dr.
Patale to come in January.
Do you want to delay that until February?
Yeah, delay that until February.
Okay.
Yeah, for obvious reasons, we want that study to be presented in detail.
So we'll have that.
Now, Mr.
Muse.
One thing that might actually help, we might not know a lot about PFPRA at this point, but PFPRA is a short chain PFAS molecule.
Most of the ones that we've been focusing on in New Hampshire have been kind of the long chain variety.
So one of the things I'm curious about is whether there's been research into the health impacts of any of these other short chain compounds.
So what do we know about short chain compounds that's different from the long chain compounds, and how does that impact how we might approach this from a health standpoint?
There are other short chain compounds that we know a little more about.
So i mean that you know if that's a topic of appropriate discussion if the commission wants to make that part of its um scope here then then you know that's something we could i mean that john patale would be in a position to talk about what we know about some of the other short chain compounds as part of a discussion on PFPRA.
That would be a February target for that.
So we can have the focus being on that specific expertise to those types of – that's a technical question that needs time to be stated and then we can learn from that.
From a discussion standpoint, I want to ask your guides, Mr.
Wimsatt as well.
The, and this is after speaking with Ms.
Dunville and EPA, this is just myself when I was trying to set up everything here.
The 70 parts per trillion is still the trigger point for treatment for PFAS.
No, in New Hampshire, we, since Since September of 2019, we've had an effect, that impose a standard of 12 parts per trillion for PFOA in drinking water and groundwater, 18 parts for terrain for PFOS, or 15, sorry, and 18 for PFHXS.
Yeah, there's one more.
And then one more PFNA, but I can't remember the exact number.
But basically, PFOA and PFOS, we have lower standards than 70, even though that number...
Now, it should be said that EPA has very recently issued a proposed change to the reference dose for PFOA and PFOA that is much lower than what they had been working with previously.
That work is proposed and it has gone to a science advisory board, or SAB, that will be taking information and testimony on that in January and February, I believe.
And then they will make a decision in April whether they want to adopt that.
And if they do, if they sort of – basically, the science advisory board is a group of toxicologists and professionals in the field who basically serve to review EPA's work.
And then once that has been completed, if they confirm that that lower reference dose is appropriate, EPA has committed to by the fall of 22, so about a year from now, proposing a new national primary drinking water standard like an MCL and an MCL level goal that would then be considered over the course of the following year and then presumably be acted on in the fall of 23.
So we're watching that with great interest because it could have the potential of lowering And If we review that and we observe that data and the experts, including our own experts, agree with it, then it could result in much lower standards than we currently have for those two compounds.
So we're looking at that with great interest at this point.
And I would just – just one last thing.
I'm approaching that because I – the 75 trillion was the benchmark that was stated in previous meetings where, with the water testing, it wasn't rising to the level of treatment.
And then when we passed, we together passed the new law, and that had those delineations.
I thought it was like 19 to 12.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to interrupt.
Well, now I'm on a roll right now.
By all means.
But the reason I brought it up was your guidance, not like today per se, but if we have this as part of our discussions going forward, is when we have a state requirement and it's for community wells and not for private homes, is that not, and I happen to be a real estate agent, is that dealing with water testing and safe drinking water, is that not what we should be doing for our standards for the state of New Hampshire, not just for community, but for all?
And then, or why not?
So, yeah, so a lot to unpack there.
So, first of all, I apologize.
I misunderstood your first question.
EPA, we do have a problem, and it's been discussed in this commission before where EPA was not really observing our new standards for PFAS and one of the reasons they weren't doing that is remedies been selected so there are some logistical machinations that occur in the Superfund process that if a remedy has already been selected unless you go back to revisit it you aren't necessarily going to identify any state standards but a real fundamental problem was the fact that pfae pfo and pfos are not identified as circular hazardous substances and that term has a very specific legal meaning and what i also want to note because maybe members not all members of the commission may know this, but as part of its PFAS action plan, EPA has stated that they intend to identify PFOS as circlas hazardous substances as early this spring of 2022.
That could have a very significant impact on the level of our authority associated with regulating PFAS compounds at Superfund sites, including the Cochlear Landfill site.
So we're looking at, with great interest, at how that advances.
So the idea is that once PFAS are identified as a circular hazardous substance, there would be a situation where, as they review and look at the remedy at Coakley and the conditions at Coakley, they would need to apply any appropriate state applicable and relevant requirements, one of which obviously would be RMCL and our ambient groundwater quality standards.
So it may give us a little – a substantial amount more authority and sort of teeth to address PFAS at Superfund sites, including Coakley.
So we're very interested in that.
Getting to your sort of real estate question, yeah, it is true that in New Hampshire, when we set a drinking water MCL, it is only enforceable on regulated public water systems, which include the big ones like Manchester and Nashua or Penichok, but also include community water systems that that are regulated and it can even go all the way down to condo associations oh sure absolutely absolutely right so so um so we have that in pretty firm uh you know we have a good robust program for implementing that and enforcing that against regulated public water systems but we don't enforce it on a private well owner we don't go to someone's house and say you've got a compound above the MCL, it's better fix it or we're going to shut you down.
Nor do we wish to possess that authority at DES.
So having said that when there is a site like, you know, for example the Sancoman site where emissions from emissions from the company have caused, as we've discussed, significant widespread impacts to drinking water, not only to public water systems, but private well with owners.
The responsible party for that does have a, even though we don't enforce the MCL or the AGQS against a private well owner, if you as a responsible party cause contamination of a private well, you absolutely have a responsibility under state law to provide safe alternate water for that private well owner.
And that's what we've been busily implementing in southern New Hampshire for coming on six years now.
Thank you for that.
Okay, we've got about two minutes left here.
Anything further for- I was just going to jump in and say that the Drinking Water Groundwater Trust Fund is going to be funding DES – I think we're voting on it this month – DES initiated program that came out of the Seacoast Drinking Water Commission looking at arsenic and other metals like manganese in private drinking water wells, but it's really clear that that everything that has to do with private wells is voluntary and except when there is contamination DES can go after the responsible party.
But but it's amazing that you can identify arsenic, which has a direct association with bladder cancer as well as neurologic problems in children, and people won't respond with an intervention.
We're trying to say, well, what if we give you that intervention, which is a filter picture, because they're easily filtered.
It does not go to PFAS, but we're looking at cancers, and arsenic is a cancer-causing agent.
Right.
I found that to be a mitigating factor is the expense for filtration, but the newer technology has point of use filtration for arsenic.
But again, it just seems in our state, this is where right here we can be a big part of working with our expertise, like yourself, as the one said, and our madam here, is the set standards of policy going forth now for decades to come.
And it's so important.
All right.
So beyond that, is there anything further, members?
Yes, sir.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I just have a quick overview of just kind of what I've heard.
As a new member, the biggest question I have is what is the scope of this commission?
It seems like we've heard today that we can't say that there is or there isn't a cancer cluster, but we know so little about these chemicals, these compounds, PFAS and PFOSA, that will there potentially be a cluster in the future?
That might be something we want to consider as a commission, because I think to what the Senator said, it's so critically important that we get this right.
So that's something to think about.
That was the biggest question I had after listening to everything.
No, and you're out of Seabrook.
Yes, sir.
And this is your first meeting?
I thank you for stepping up.
My pleasure.
And for being here.
Let me recognize Senator Sherman.
Yeah, just to answer at least one part of that, There is a cancer cluster that was demonstrated back in 19, I'm sorry, in 2016 with a statistical analysis of the cases of RMS and PPB.
The good news is at least in the state registry, we haven't seen any more cases.
But out of that investigation, I was chair of the governor's task force on the Seacoast Cancer Cluster under Maggie Hassan and then Governor Sununu.
And what we did discover was that there were multiple potential contributing factors, including Seabrook Nuclear Power Plant, which by the way, no definite contribution from any of these, but areas of concern by the public, including Shiller Power Station, the Navy shipyard, we looked at all of these.
But the one that was right in our backyard was Coakley and Pease.
And so what we've learned from all of this over time is a lot of what you heard today, which is not only is there important, have we seen important progress in the state on some of these contaminants, but they're also statewide.
statewide as Mike said we have Superfund sites how many 150 or that's how many 21 with 150 closed landfills.
So, you know, the problem, it's what we learned in the seacoast, we can expand it statewide and really be a little bit smarter as we move through.
And a lot of the stuff that we've done out of this commission and out of the work that's been done by Whitney and by Mike has set some of the national standards, which is really impressive for New Hampshire.
Now, just to add one other thing, if I can get the data to you, but when this was originally put together, it was called the Cancer Cluster Investigation, and it was putting information together.
The intent was for a full understanding of the situation in the Seacoast area specific to a cancer cluster and what it meant, what it is, what do you do going forward.
What it's now evolved into based on House Bill 1264, PFAS has taken place.
And so now that is part of the work that needs to be done and there's funding functions in it.
You can bring it up on the web.
And also, you've got a copy of 1264 right there.
I wanted to make sure everybody had a copy of it.
And that was recommended by Rep.
Abrami.
So we all have the same benchmark.
The benchmark of a starting point has been adjusted.
It's 1264 now.
But before it was information gathering with a recommendation of action.
This is now dealing with much more technical information that is now available because of the work done by, again, Ms.
Hammond and our DES.
And so we've gone quite a distance from when this started.
But it's time now for action based on empirical data and recommendations.
And these studies had to be done.
That's what's been rather a challenge, is waiting for studies to be completed before you make a responsible decision.
Because once it's done, I don't see, it's not likely to happen again.
And the reason is, it's a lot of work and a lot of time to wait for studies to be done.
We now have this work being completed, and we can move forward with a substantive policy recommendation in June, and then with new legislation, with all of us still being here, to come and to be proposed in the fall, and I'm talking the fall of 2022.
So that's my personal synopsis of where we are right now and uh senator gray anything uh no i do want to ask the question offline oh then offline madame hammond with the senator uh okay we'll call the meeting uh to end right now and thank you very much for coming here.
Our next meeting will be, because we have collaborative consensus here, it's January 24th as recommended by Ms.
Dunville of our EPA representative and our EPA person, that they be ready on that date.
That's where that date came from.
And then we'll also have further update and guidance from Ms.
Hammond on that subject, on the cancer cluster issues that we discussed today as well.
Those are the two issues that will be on the agenda, right?
Nothing further at this point.
And then February, we'll confirm the February date because a lot of bills are being heard and so on what the availability is.
And on that date is when we'll get the expertise in terms of the other points that came up today.
All right.
Thank you very much and we'll call the meeting to order.
It is now